if you want to hear all the details
about singing tap that aren't even in
the movies that stick around to the end
of this video this video sponsored by
Nord BPM get 70% off a three-year plan
by signing up at Nord VPN comm /c Z's
world the Saw franchise features a long
line of law enforcers who have tried to
solve the jigsaw case and put an end to
the killings that take place in their
city from detective Carey to detective
Mathews to officer Rigg to Detective
lieutenant Hoffman Gibson Fisk Johnston
Halloran and hunt but none were on to
jigsaw before the duo of David Tapp and
Stevenson welcome to horror history my
name's Jeff and today's lesson will be
analyzing a pair of the Metropolitan
Police Department's finest David Tapp
and Steven sang sing and tap play very
important roles in the bathroom game
that took place in October 2004 but
before we can get there we've got to
study all the events that led up to that
point so I'm gonna put the horror
history screen now David Tapp was born I
don't know probably in the 40s I'm not
sure how old he's supposed to be but we
do know that his partner Steven sang was
born in 1976 because his age at the time
of death is stated to be 28 years old a
raid that also resulted in the death of
taps partner 28-year old Steven Singh
before the jigsaw case it seems that
they spend most of their time dealing
with low-level Street gangsters one of
the gangs they busted was called Keisuke
after locking them up their territory
was still marked with graffiti a lasting
reminder of the damage they caused to
the community the first we see of Tappin
saying investigating the jigsaw case was
at the crime scene of Paul in the spring
of 2004 they check things out with
detective Alison Carey and I think her
liens suggest that Paul may not have
been the first victim that these three
encountered this one's not fresh anymore
at least three weeks out but they must
be pretty new to the jigsaw saga overall
at this point the younger of the two
Singh looks like he's never smelled the
corpse in decay before tap on the other
hand doesn't seem distracted by the
stench and is able to fully focus on the
contents of the tape found at the crime
scene where in a jigsaw calls Paul out
on acts of self-harm and tells him if he
wants to live he'll have to cut himself
again by crawling through a cage filled
with razor wire to reach the door I
think one of the reasons that's happened
saying worked well together is that
their skill sets complement each other
for example tap seems to have a greater
attention to detail he's the one noticed
the jigsaw piece cut out of Paul's
shoulder the origin of the nickname that
newspapers would begin using to refer to
the killer at some point Singh is shown
going inside the cage for a closer look
so I think tapped being the senior calls
the shots while Singh is the hands-on
guy they aren't able to gain any
suspects from the razor wire trapped but
in the meantime they aren't busy with
other cases and bring in a pedo dentist
something that sounds like it could be
the subject of its own horror movie not
long after the three of them
investigated the flammable jelly truck
where a man named Mark Wilson is tested
by jigsaw for faking his illness
he'd been tasked with getting the
combination to a safe written on the
wall of the darkroom his only source of
light is a small candle and he's covered
in flammable gel also the floor is
covered in broken glass as if jigsaw
hired link to come in and do his thing
is there anything more satisfying than
ants no no there is not Tapp orders
carried to have a penlight found at the
crime scene tested for fingerprints
leading them to an oncologist named dr.
Lawrence Gordon they turned up with the
angel of Mercy Hospital recordin Works
and asked him for his whereabouts the
previous night when he's unable to
provide that information they asked him
to come down to the police station after
initial hesitation Gordon gives an alibi
his mistress who he was meeting in
secret at a seedy motel around that same
time a survivor of one of jigsaws games
comes into the station to file a police
report a woman by the name of Amanda
young the detectives were able to clear
Gordon's name but they asked him to stay
a little bit longer and listen to
Amanda's testimony because everyone is
still confused by how Gordon's penlight
ended up at the crime scene she tells
them that she's actually grateful to
jigsaw for his task for helping her
overcome her drug addiction still not
convinced that Gordon is innocent
detective Tapp becomes obsessed with the
video tape recovered from the room that
a man that had been trapped in for the
next two weeks he studies it over and
over probably going through boxes and
boxes of delicious donuts to the point
that saying notices his partner delving
into insanity
a tap I don't mean for this to be
disrespectful maybe you should find
yourself a girlfriend just that in a tap
notices something that gives him an
epiphany about the possible whereabouts
of jigsaw he sees graffiti with the
symbol of the gang k2k who they busted
before the jigsaw saga Singh remembers
that they had a small territory only
about four blocks narrowing down their
search area considerably tap also here's
a fire alarm in the background somehow
honestly I always thought this was
ridiculous play the clip
[Applause]
they're able to get a list from the fire
departments of every emergency in that
neighborhood over a two-week period and
this further narrows down the options to
an old mannequin Factory I think we have
enough for a warrant though you say -
the thing about a warrant breaking the
law breaking the law
inside they discover a model version of
what would be jigsaws next game though
singing tap did not know it yet they do
know that they're in the right place
however because they discovered Billy
the puppets the same avatar used in the
Amanda young tape tap uncovers a man
being held captive
they were about to experience one of
jigsaws traps firsthand but what they
did not anticipate was that they would
be the ones who are tested as the
transgressions of the notorious killer
jigsaw swelled to the horror of the
public consciousness citizens began to
change their lives to protect themselves
and avoid falling into one of his many
traps you too need to protect yourself
from the traps of the digital world
that's why I recommend an order VPN when
you're not using Nord VPN ISPs
governments and hackers can see exactly
what you're doing online but by
connecting indoors fast and secure
servers your data will be encrypted
twice as it travels through the cloud so
your privacy is protected I think it's
something that every single Internet
user should have to stay safe online
with my deal you're gonna be able to get
Nord bpn for as low as 350 per month
with a three year plan which is already
worth it to protect yourself but also it
pays for itself with what you can do
with it today I had to send some big
files to an editor the free version of
the service that I use only lets me send
a couple of files per day so once I hit
my limit I just switched on the VPN now
it looks like someone new is sending the
files because it's a new IP address and
I can keep doing this as much as I want
so that just saved me 12 bucks per month
as a horror movie fan Nord VPN is a
dream let's say I want to watch a jigsaw
nope not on Netflix or at least not on
Netflix in my country but I bet it's
available in another country so I'll
just look it up change the best Canadian
server and there it is I saved another
10 bucks you can do the same thing on
geo lock to youtube videos to open up a
whole new world of concepts all you need
to do to get started is visiting or to
VPN comm /d zis world with my link
they're giving you 70% off a three year
plan plus one month for free all it
takes is one click for online security
that's noir to VPN comm /c ZZZ world
as jigsaw could be heard coming in on
the noisy elevator down the hall the two
partners had different ideas of how to
handle the situation Singh the younger
less experienced one is excited to catch
the increasingly infamous serial killer
but tap had the foresight to wait so
that they could catch him in the act and
maybe learn a thing or two about him
before putting him away if they could
they may be better prepared to pin all
of the killings on him in court these
viewpoints go back to the roles that I
mentioned earlier with tap being the
head and Singh being the hands they hide
and watch as the hooded figure goes to
investigate the disturbance in his
latest prisoner their mistake here is
being unprepared as they vastly
underestimate jigsaws intelligence and
ability to think ahead and anticipate
jigsaw has been expecting them and
although he doesn't show it he knows
that they're in the room as soon as he
comes in so when they come out to arrest
him jigsaw puts his plan into action
stepping on a button that starts the
trap a pair of drills close in on the
prisoners head and jigsaw tells sing and
tap that they must choose what's more
important making the arrest or saving
the life of another man while Singh
tries to figure out which key to use tap
make sure that jigsaw doesn't escape so
in the eyes of jigsaw Singh has passed
this test by showing compassion for
human life and tap has failed due to his
obsession with catching jigsaw Singh is
able to stop the progress of the drills
by shooting them but jigsaw pulls a
blade and cuts taps throat before making
his escape Singh tells his partner
that'll come back for him not realizing
that he's still under jigsaws judgment
and by chasing after jigsaw while his
friend continues to suffer he's making
the same mistake that tap made at just
moments before he chases jigsaw
downstairs into a hallway and orders him
to freeze when jigsaw continues to flee
he fires a shot in jigsaw hits the floor
I've said throughout this video that
Tappin Singh's skill sets complement
each other but with tap no longer there
to offer his wisdom saying he makes one
rookie mistake and this time it's fatal
he fails to realize that this whole
scenario was a little too easy with the
greatest criminal mind the city has ever
seen just walk out into an open fire
like that with no protection Singh
doesn't consider the idea that jigsaw
was faking it and the mistake leads him
right into the next trap a fishing wire
obscured by some Halloween store cobwebs
which sets off a row of loaded weapons
getting deserved all Singh had to do a
past jigsaws test would have been to
stay back and help his suffering
partners but his thirst to take down the
man that they've been looking for
outweighs the magnitude of a moral
Tigra tap struggles down the stairs just
in time to see jigsaw get up and walk
away from the remains of sings now
lifeless body if there's a moment that
defines david tap that dictates his
course in action from here on out it is
this image of his trusted partner saying
who had died trying to bring their
greatest adversary to justice to this
point he had shown signs of obsession
with the case spending many hours
studying the Amanda young tape but this
was the moment when the obsession turns
from determination to iron and a deep
yearning for revenge this was the moment
where tap went off the deep end in the
aftermath of this event david was
discharged from the metropolitan police
force I'm the grounds of entering
without a warrant so he ended up
continuing to investigate on his own
that summer as the scar on his throat
slowly heals he went deeper and deeper
down the rabbit hole dedicating his life
to finding and stopping the man who
killed his partner and attempted to take
his life due to jigsaws oversized hood
and robes tap never got a good look at
his face
and thus still suspected Lawrence Gordon
as his primary suspect he went out and
rented himself an apartment with an
excellent view of Gordon's home which he
would use to spy on the doctor and his
family over the course of the next five
months the apartment was also used as a
headquarters which is absolutely
littered with newspaper clippings tapes
photographs and other documents what
little space he had left was designated
to take out boxes and also this crazed
picture of Rick Sanchez for some reason
perhaps just to depict taps manic state
and complete loss of touch with reality
at the hands of his fixation in October
of 2004 tap is starting to run out of
leaves and hires a photographer named
Adam Stan Hyde to follow Gordon around
all he's out and about hoping he can
snap some evidence proving that the
doctor is the killer he uses a pseudonym
Bob and pays Adam $200 each night on the
third night Adam and Lawrence are both
captured and put into jigsaws game in a
dilapidated bathroom while tap watches
the window of Gordon's home and notices
a mysterious man in there while the
doctor is not home he realizes that
something is very wrong when he hears
gunshots even in his deteriorated mental
state his goal is still to serve justice
he loads his weapon and runs across the
street to find Gordon's wife Alison in
the midst of a struggle with the man
he'd seen in the window I think this is
where Taft finally realizes that
Lawrence Gordon is not the perpetrator
of these games and traps he and his
family are victims of it he battles with
the captor who channels his inner link
and smashes a vase over
cops had and attempts to make his
getaway as soon as he's able to get back
to his feet he goes after the man who
leads him to the location that Gordon
and Adam are being held at this point
tap must be pretty convinced that he is
right on this hill of jigsaw and doesn't
hold anything back in his fiery pursuit
but as I've said over sixty nine times
over the course of this video tap is
just one half of a two-person team he's
been working solo for five months but in
this final chase he misses his late
partner Singh and more than ever because
Singh was always the hands-on guy the
guy who would take those shots while tap
plans what to do next but as tap was
likely in his late 50s at this point he
didn't have the strength he once did and
at the end of a long chase Zep is able
to overpower him and do away with the
ex-cop once and for all so that was the
end of the buddy cop duo the first in a
long line of police officers who would
fall during jigsaws active years nearly
two years later in April of 2006 the
officers are honored in a public Police
ceremony and photographs in both sing
and tap can be seen on the memorial to
be honest I don't really know what tap
is on there because he was no longer a
cop when he died and the location of the
bathroom wasn't discovered until the
years later so they wouldn't have
actually even found his body yet but I
mean he did contribute a lot of
information to the case so I love that
one slide now if you want more on tap if
you're just craving more tap and you're
probably an alcoholic no but tap story
does continue on and saw the video game
yes I know jigsaw but the video game is
not canon it doesn't count as a part of
the story so I'm not gonna cover it here
in horror history because it would just
create problems with the timeline but it
would be open to playing it if that's
something you want to see the basic gist
of it though is that tap survives the
gunshot but somehow finds himself in the
reverse bear trap and once he gets out
of it he has to save all these people
from traps and then at the end he chases
down jigsaw and is faced once again with
the decision that he had to make at the
mannequin Factory either get the victims
to safety or continue to go after jigsaw
then there's also the sequel to the
video game which involves taps son that
he apparently has but I think that's
really getting off-topic
and the death bells about to ring so I
think this class is gonna be dismissed
for the homework just make sure you like
this video and let me know in the
comments which character you'd like to
see me cover next on horror history and
as always check out the playlist on the
left to see the histories of other saw
characters and remember to subscribe to
see ZZZ world for new Horrors every week
ring that bell for notifications and
I'll see you in the next one
assuming we both survive